[Music]
we're going to start this one off with a
picture let's see if anybody knows how
to identify this thing i got to do let
me see it's always fun yeah i can't put
this in the center because i opened the
picture like this but here we go do you
see that everybody see it nah is that a
giant snake slowly
notice the scale is that a snake
what the [ __ ] that's a crazy ass eel
don't even know what i'm looking at
that's a ceo the scale of it i mean it's
[ __ ] big is that a snake or what it's
a sea eel
yeah seal or sea eel
or as a whale
it's a ceo so a group of fishermen from
the city of erica recently caught a
colossal
oarfish is what it is
also known as a rowing fish so it's not
an eel it's a fish it's that like thin
weird long one that looks like this yeah
but the reason why obviously this is
crazy because it's a [ __ ] giant 16
foot long [ __ ] it's huge huge
right
but it's actually considered to be to be
even see a creature like this is uh
believed to be a sign of pending
disaster oh so it's not good luck yeah
it's traditionally seen as a bad omen
mm-hmm so why do they catch it who's the
authority the thing is a bad omen it's
not about like trying to catch it but
it's traditionally seen as battle
because they're normally supposed to be
very very very very deep seed dwelling
creatures
so any time any time that they come up
to the surface is a bad omen for things
like tsunamis earthquakes
and or
they caught them before i love that i
love when traditional like bad omen
things end up being logically useful
yeah yeah that's fine i was [ __ ] on
it and then now i'm like yeah now i feel
like an [ __ ] i feel like a piece of
[ __ ] you think it will taste good if we
steam it yeah
with
ginger and scallions
little scallions
no ginger no have you had the korean
belt fish no oh like they have a long
belt fish like that that they chop up
and then they pan fry it i feel like
it's gonna taste like that's what i'm
saying it would be it would taste good
yeah everybody's like this is a bad omen
he's like this looks like a good recipe
[Laughter]
so you're just eating it
damn that sucks
but it tastes good very bad so
yeah so ore fish usually live in the
depths it said that when they start to
the surface it's because the tectonic
plates are in movement whoa
they get disturbed wow
i do too this one is off the coast of
chile oh
in a city of erica so they're about to
have a bad time over there they might
get a tsunami mimi
so they could get a quake maybe yeah
they they're it's it's very popularized
to be understood that they've been long
seen as an omen for oncoming tsunamis
and earthquakes by japanese people who
also believe whoever finds one will be
cursed as well by the way so let's jump
in that's taking it too far
that's a that's a japanese oh man this
is that's not logical that doesn't
explain [ __ ] that's taking it too far
it's a richter scale let's leave it at
that so reaching lengths of up to 11
meters the fish live in deep water and
only return to the surface when they're
sick dying or breeding so he might be
dead he might be or [ __ ]
fueled speculation they may return the
surface with changes in the weather so
that's also a possibility yeah but
weather's always changing though weather
is always changing they need to make up
their mind they just gave us like eight
different [ __ ] theories this is now
losing its magic yeah it's like a
horoscope right it's like oh you are you
always are really good at making
decisions unless it's that's complex
you're usually really happy on sundays
unless you're not yeah you know this
just like webmd when you see the
symptoms and everything is flu-like
symptoms yeah they're [ __ ] telling us
who likes symptoms about the [ __ ]
diagnosis death yeah yeah yeah at the
very fish is the world's longest yeah
longest bony fish uh and is rarely seen
because it lives at considerable depths
of around 3 300 feet or a thousand
meters
so is that i wonder if that's is that
already a known scientific thing that
when deep sea [ __ ] comes up that's like
a bad sign of something i think if they
have i think historically we're being
racist man
we got to integrate let's let's invite
these fish you know maybe so we could
eat we're being racist to the fish
because we're so mad at them why so
you're trying to beat them about race
equality we're missing so much delicious
tolerance
we're just making up stuff about them
right now but what if these fishermen
have just really long [ __ ] you know
lines and they can reach these decks
exactly is that a potential we're being
racist by going hey that fish got a lamp
on its head stay down there yeah yeah we
don't like your kind around here you
don't even need that up here it's always
bright
this neighborhood is ours
not for you we're all italian what is
wrong with you your skin see through get
out of here
[ __ ] weirdo
it doesn't matter with you i can see
your [ __ ] organs get out of here
piece of [ __ ] you're [ __ ] scaring
everybody all right
coming out here with the whole
translucent
this is fun this is wild man yeah i like
this aquatic hate i know aquatica
there's a strong possibility that uh you
know oarfish of ancient and historical
tales uh were the creatures of like you
know sea serpent fairy tales and sea
monsters and stuff like that loch ness
or whatever because i bet you if i
[ __ ] saw an oar fish swimming at the
surface i would probably pull out my
phone and be like oh my god right same
[ __ ] it's like the giant squid legends
right how they thought it was like uh
yeah matt but it's but it's really just
like a big-ass squid stuck on a boat
yeah do these oar fish swim like this is
that why they call it or do they swim
like that like a no i think it's a flat
one though because why do they call it
an oar fish i thought
they would swim like an oar like a
seahorse either or fish or roast they
can swim either or oh wow
see you guys this guy is
[ __ ] good guys
let me see if i could youtube a video of
oarfish yeah let's see what that [ __ ]
looks like
i want to see an ore feel like it's
going to make us more racist though i
want to see it
yeah it's gonna fuel my hate it's gonna
give jason more ways to like cook maybe
we could fry yeah
actually i think he's better deep fried
yeah all right here we go
it's all about the music
[Music]
15th century [ __ ] sailors were
looking at it like i'm gonna fold that
mermaid those are the beluga whales
they used to look like
that's a mermaid dude let's come on her
lucas got some cheeks on her jug
yo that's pretty crazy though i would
freak the [ __ ] out if i saw that in the
ocean
and dude imagine it like thrashing
around because the water's right they
mainly eat tiny plankton though so they
are not actually dangerous for humans
that's really good yeah
that's your [ __ ] catchphrase dude
that's where it is
just two george merchants in the water
like this
all of this footage
oh [ __ ] out of here dude what's that one
whoa what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] looks like
an alien man no idea what you're
translucent
i know it's screen saver when i see one
that's fake
that's not real hey be immune
is the [ __ ]
hair like the the tentacles or whatever
the [ __ ] it is i see here it looks like
a goddamn raver that's edc dude it's a
mohawk bruh that shit's on fire
that shit's sparkling you ever see those
videos with those giant catfish and how
big those [ __ ] yeah yeah like
those those won't be sharks like this
you know what i mean you can pet them
they're [ __ ] huge and they pull them
out the water i'm like jesus christ it's
crazy how if you guys ever been fishing
it's pretty crazy how heavy [ __ ] fish
especially when they start freaking out
it's like hard to keep and then like you
know there's pictures where they're
holding it it's like they don't get
enough credit that thing's probably
[ __ ] heavy you gotta kill it first
it hurts your hand now people always go
like this and hold their mouth like this
yeah and then i tried one with a small
one i was like dude this hurt my thumb
yeah dude they'd be sucking on your
finger and [ __ ] no it's their teeth yeah
yeah
you gotta get used to when you're like
fishing the crazy thing is the second
you like put your thumb in their mouth
and you hold it up they stop wiggling
right yeah it's like a [ __ ] motor
thing yeah
if you're fishing and stuff like that
and you're trying to take it off the
hook they're like thrashing around the
second you put your thumb in their mouth
it opens up their gills and then they
stop moving is that kind of like is that
kind of like pit bulls where they stop
attacking when you put your thumb in
their ass yes i don't think that works
that's just joe that's what they say if
joe gets all crazy we put a thumb in his
ass he goes alright
we should ask the jiu jitsu expert here
yeah hey does that world check right
does it do you put a thumb in a guy's
ass and then he kind of freezes no it's
actually the opposite like i feel like
i'm okay this is this is actually really
stupid but back in the day when we used
to train and we were like back in the
dark ages of mma we used to do this
drill where
we had a hard time getting off our back
and that's like a paradigm in mma where
a guy could hold you down and we weren't
very good wrestlers so we had to like
come up with our own ways
so our buddy would be on his back a guy
would be on top and the guy on top his
job was to hold him down the whole time
and then let the bottom guy get out and
he couldn't get out so then we used to
get towels and try to whip our homie on
the bottom and he would get out every
single time he would like freak the [ __ ]
out and like get enough of a [ __ ]
energy like only encouragement yeah a
low key probably with a finger in the
ass like there's been times where like
as jokes we try to like put fingers in
our butts you know i mean and see what
happens and they freak out and they they
get out of position really easily but
when it usually came to nick he just
relaxed i started pushing back on that
like whoa what are you doing what are
you doing
he just opens up and blossoms like a
beautiful butterfly
yeah he enjoys the ride that's my style
so if you guys want to take classes for
me hit me up at lion park academy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you